mein name ist gerhard lauer ich bin
professor für deutsche männer teams an
der universität basel
wer sie liest wo und auf welche weise
eigentlich im digitalen zeitalter
dieser frage geht meinen vortrag nach
ich versuche zu zeigen dass nicht eine
völlig andere literatur entstanden ist
im digitalen zeitalter
im gegenteil viele formen sind sich
ziemlich ähnlich geblieben was sich aber
ändern ist das digitale teilen von
literatur das sprechen und das intensive
identifizieren mit literatur literatur
zählt zu unserem digitalen leben sehr
eng dazu wo das alles stattfindet das
zeigt meinen vortrag